si observamos este éter podemos notar
que tiene grupos r a ambos lados del
oxígeno y si quisiéramos nombrar éter es
hay un par de formas para hacerlo
comenzaremos con la forma común
para nombrar éter es que sigue el
procedimiento en el que primero
nombramos uno de los grupos
tilo
unidos al oxígeno luego nombramos al
otro grupo
cielo
seguido de la palabra
éter
así
queda al kiel al kiel éter veamos un
ejemplo de nomenclatura común
comenzaremos con esta molécula de aquí
entonces si quisiera nombrar este éter
primero tengo que ver qué tipo de grupos
alquilo hay unidos al oxígeno en el lado
izquierdo
hay un grupo metilo y en el lado derecho
tenemos un grupo
y lo tenemos que pensar en el orden
alfabético sabemos que la eba antes que
la m por lo que vamos a escribir
antes que metil entonces se va a llamar
útil
mills
ter
así hagamos otro ejemplo
muy bien nuestro objetivo es nombrar
este éter primero vamos a ver qué grupos
alquilo tenemos unidos al oxígeno del
lado izquierdo
reconocemos a este grupo como un ser
útil y del lado derecho tenemos un grupo
metilo entonces considerando el orden
alfabético la b va antes que la m por lo
que el grupo está útil o va a ir antes
que el grupo metilo en el nombre
entonces se deberá de llamar
til
me
etc
la parte de erc no se considera en el
orden alfabético solo comparamos útil
con metil muy bien ahora aún cuando te
útil metil éter puede ser el nombre
correcto
probablemente probablemente no es el
nombre que se usaría en un laboratorio
usualmente se le llama metil ser útil
éter o
m
d
mtb es un solvente orgánico muy común
tiene muchos usos y de nuevo mtp es el
nombre más usado pero técnicamente no es
el nombre correcto
ahora veamos un éter que tiene dos
grupos alquilo iguales si tenemos esta
molécula como nuestro éter tenemos dos
grupos de tilo en esta por lo que lo
llamaremos dietil éter
tels
éter
usaremos el prefijo día aquí el 10 y el
éter es por supuesto el más famoso este
es en el que todos piensan cuando
piensan en éter es veamos otra manera de
nombrar éteres y esta es la manera y pac
oficial de nombrarlos la forma común de
nombrar éter es es tan común que es
aceptada por la nomenclatura iupac pero
hay una manera iupac de hacerlo para
moléculas más complicadas se hacen
nombrando al éter como un sustituye ente
al que llamamos
sí
entonces vamos a nombrarlos c3 como
sustituyen test y van a tener un al
canon como nombre principal lo
llamaremos al cox y al
cano
así entonces lo que haremos es si
tuviéramos este
genérico de aquí
r oh repriman buscaríamos al grupo al
kilo más largo y ese sería el nombre
principal si el grupo r prima fuera mi
cadena más larga de carbono ese sería mi
nombre alcano principal y luego
nombraría esta porción de molécula como
un sustituye en teal cox y en tu
alcance' o
veamos un ejemplo de nomenclatura iupac
entonces vamos a vamos a nombrar el
primer éter que hicimos hace unos
minutos el primero que hicimos cuando
estábamos haciendo nomenclatura común lo
llamamos et y metil éter
ahora vamos a nombrarlo usando
nomenclatura iupac lo que haremos es
buscar el grupo más largo y ese será mi
nombre principal entonces mi grupo más
largo será este lado derecho y si lo
numerados podemos decir que este es
número 1 y número 2
así en número 1 y número 2 si quisieras
no es necesario hacerlo para este
ejemplo pero solo para que pienses en la
cadena más larga de carbono que sería
que sería un neta no voy a escribir
no como el nombre alcano principal y
luego que está unido a esa parte de tano
de la molécula es un sustituye ente r
qué es la porción éter lo nombraremos
como un alcohol y dado que tenemos sólo
un carbono
sabemos que utilizamos la raíz met y
como un alcohol si sería med occ si
entonces el nombre iupac completo para
esta molécula sería m
sí
eta no no tenemos que preocuparnos por
los números ya que sólo tenemos 2
carbonos en la cadena principal entonces
me tocó 7 no sería el nombre iupac para
esta molécula el nombre común sería el
metil éter ambos nombres son correctos
hagamos otro ejemplo en el que tengamos
una molécula similar excepto que en este
caso le añadiremos otro carbono aquí si
pienso en el arcano principal aquí en la
derecha tendría tres carbonos para el
arcano principal si quisiera a
numerarlos sería uno dos y tres un
arcano de tres carbonos es por supuesto
un propano entonces escribo pero
para no
aquí y busco me sustituyen teal cox y
otra vez y observo cuántos carbonos
tiene
sólo uno solo hay un carbono en este
sustituye ente por lo que una vez más
sería un me toque si voy a escribir me
tóxica aquí y quedaría como me
todo sí
pero para no esta vez debo poner un
número ahí y ese grupo está unido al
carbono 2 por lo que el nombre completo
sería 2 me talks y propano muy bien
ahora hagamos un ejemplo más complicado
que tiene un poco de estéreo química si
esta fuera la molécula que estuviera
nombrando
le vamos a agregar un bromo aquí así muy
bien entonces para está una vez más
tengo que pensar en el grupo más grande
como mi nombre principal si veo esos dos
grupos alquilo el que se ve más grande
es el que está en la izquierda y quiero
enumerar de manera que me sustituye
entes tengan el número más bajo posible
entonces se observó el lado izquierdo
puedo ver que hay cuatro carbonos en mi
sustituye ente más largo por lo que
cuatro carbonos era mi nombre principal
entonces vamos a llamarlo butano vamos a
empezar a escribir butano aquí entonces
sería vu
no
por ahora y cuando número s fruta no
quiero que me sustituye entes tengan el
número más bajo posible entonces podría
empezar por la izquierda o por la
derecha sería más lógico empezar por la
derecha ya que tendría un sustituye ente
unido al carbono 1
y tendría otro sustituye ente unido al
carbono 2 y luego están el 3
bien entonces si pienso en esos dos
sustituye entes pensemos en cómo los
nombrar y amos del lado derecho para mí
sustituye ente al cox y esta vez hay dos
carbonos en mi sustituye ente al cox y
justo aquí
y 2 carbonos serían et entonces sería
tóxico y stock si está unido al carbono
1 entonces puedo empezar a escribir eso
aquí 1
sí
butano es lo que tengo hasta ahora y
también tengo un bromo unido al carbono
2 entonces sería 2 bromo entonces
escribimos 2
pero no
1 top sí y eso sigue el orden alfabético
porque la beba antes que light quedando
2 bromo 1 talks y butano y luego tenemos
que preocuparnos por la configuración
absoluta de este carbono de aquí el
carbono 2 es un carbono quiral por lo
que tenemos que pensar en cómo asignar
prioridades a esos cuatro grupos
si pienso en si pienso en los átomos
directamente unidos a mi carbono kirk al
primero identificaremos el carbono
quiral que sería este de aquí tiene
cuatro grupos diferentes unidos a él ya
que también hay un hidrógeno saliendo
del plano lejos de mí y pienso en los
números atómicos bien
tengo carbono contra carbono contra
bromo aquí bromo por supuesto tiene el
mayor número atómico tiene la prioridad
más alta ahora mi hidrógeno por supuesto
tiene la prioridad más baja sería la
prioridad número 4 y ahora tenemos dos
grupos que clasificar tengo 2 carbonos
que clasificar
voy a señalar esos carbonos de nuevo
cuál de estos carbonos tendrá la
prioridad más alta pues depende de a que
estén unidos el carbono de la izquierda
está unido a otro carbono
y dos hidrógenos el carbono de la
derecha está unido a un oxígeno
hidrógenos en términos de número atómico
carbono contra oxígeno el oxígeno gana y
entonces el carbono de la derecha tendrá
la prioridad más alta le vamos a
escribir un
aquí toda la parte de la derecha tendrá
un número 2 y del lado izquierdo
tendríamos el número
entonces tenemos 123 girando en este
sentido en contra de las manecillas del
reloj que es la configuración absoluta s
por lo que
2 bromo 1 stocks y butano sería el
nombre final
hagamos un ejemplo más de nomenclatura
de éter es ahora vamos a ver uno que
tenga un anillo
y le pondremos un doble enlace al anillo
y luego tendremos nuestro éter
del lado derecho muy bien entonces si
quisiera nombrar esta molécula pensaría
en mis dos grupos al kilo y pensaría en
cuál es el más largo por supuesto todo
esto del lado izquierdo será mi nombre
principal y luego esto va a ser me
sustituyen al coxis
del lado izquierdo sé de qué molécula se
trata sí que se llama ciclo exe no
porque lo vimos en otro vídeo entonces
tendremos ciclo externo como nombre
principal si cloud
de seno
ahora tengo que enumerar mi anillo para
dar al sustituye en teal cox y el número
más bajo posible
entonces si quisiera numerar mi anillo
para dar al sustituye en teal cox y el
número más bajo posible debería empezar
aquí y numerar 12
4 así ahora si pensamos en qué es ese
sustituye ente al coc si es un grupo
stocks y un sustituye ente stock sí
porque tengo dos carbonos aquí entonces
tengo un stock si unido al carbono 4 por
lo que sería 4
toc sí
y si quisieras puedes poner un 1 aquí 1
ciclo exc no puedes no ponerlo si
quieres también realmente no importa
pero 4 detox y 1 ciclo externo nos da
toda la información que necesitamos si
quisiéramos dibujar esta molécula
y eso es todo en cuanto al nomenclátor
adt eres